well the gop is going to be the party of  supporting law enforcement law  enforcement includes the fbi and they  didn't go in there with fbi raid jackets  they tried to constrain  their behavior carrying out that warrant  they're real i really think that the  republicans ought to thank that the  regime's secret police for going in and  raiding the home of the chief political  rival to the president the former  president unprecedented we should be  thankful they didn't even wear their fbi  jackets because they were so ashamed of  what they were doing because they wanted  to hide the fact that the biden  administration was wielding the fbi to  attack the political opponents  we ought to be listen if we're going to  be pro  law and order  we need to support extremely corrupt law  enforcement agencies do we i don't think  that's true what are you talking about  no i  i support the fbi when the fbi is acting  in a just and proper manner